[Music]
I want you to see something
you ready this is a giant map of
Switzerland
I love Switzerland and one thing I have
learned about Switzerland is that the
Swiss liked to be neutral this country
does not like conflict they avoid it at
all costs which is strange because
they're really good at fighting other
European countries used to hire Swiss
men to fight their Wars for them but
back home in Switzerland they don't
fight they don't take sides that's
partly because they lost a few wars of
expansion and kind of just decided it
was probably better to just stay put but
it's also because back when Europe was
full of Empires the big European powers
thought it would be a good idea to have
a mountainous small buffer country in
between some of the big rival powers and
so Switzerland was kind of deemed this
neutral power but the result is that
today Switzerland doesn't take sides
they don't send their troops to fight in
other Wars they rarely join alliances I
mean they're not a part of the EU
they're not a part of NATO and they
reluctantly barely joined the UN as
recently as 2002 a decade after North
Korea and the only countries that joined
after them didn't exist before then
meaning they came into existence after
2002 so they couldn't have joined before
then Switzerland is serious about
neutrality no conflict no alliances
leave us alone when you're right here
right at the crossroads of people trying
to take over Europe staying out of
conflict has big benefits for your
country and its economy but it also
means staying neutral is really hard but
the Swiss have done it using their
mountains to an exceptional engineering
obsessive commitment and a healthy
amount of explosives the Swiss have kept
empires out of their country sticking to
their guns and stayin neutral even when
Europe was tearing itself apart
so you're Switzerland in the 1940s
here's your situation you're surrounded
by Nazi Germany to your north and
fascist Italy to yourself and quickly
are becoming engulfed with all the
countries that are now in the sphere of
influence of these countries you're
surrounded and Hitler is winning
everywhere but you're Switzerland and so
you're like don't invade us we're not
gonna fight it we're not taking sides
we'll just keep trading with whoever
wants to trade with us but we're not
gonna fight or be invaded and no that's
not how Europe was in the 1940s you
couldn't just sit it out and yet the
Swiss were committed to doing so the
fact is that even with this commitment
to neutrality an invasion from their
next-door neighbor the Third Reich was a
very real possibility
so Switzerland devised what I argue is
just the most Swiss plan ever to stay
neutral during World War Two and future
global conflicts it's a plan that still
lives on today that you can still see
when you go to Switzerland here's what
it looks like first up they looked
around their country at any linkages to
the outside
they chose key points around the country
that would give invading armies access
to the country like roads bridges
tunnels any access point and then they
packed it full of explosives dynamite
TNT whatever anything that would just
completely destroy that linkage they got
really inventive with this stuff
sometimes they would wire a bridge with
dynamite but they also would put secret
cannons in mountains that would pop out
and point at a major road and demolish
it if needed making it unusable or
sometimes they would go to their long
tunnels like this ten kilometre tunnel
down here at the border with Italy and
they would rig it with TNT so that they
could quickly seal off this part of
their mountainous southern border
[Music]
up on mountain passes that even ripped
the sides of mountains with explosives
to create artificial landslides to block
the road the thinking here is that if an
invading army were marching into
Switzerland they could pull the trigger
on all this stuff igniting dynamite or
shelling or otherwise destroying all the
ways to get into the country making it a
lot harder to invade and giving them
time to retreat to the mountains
there's a wonderful strange irony going
on here the Swiss are really good at
transportation the trains are immaculate
and efficient and go up crazy mountains
and are always on time roam around the
country and you'll see this these are
the little doors in the streets where
they would pack explosives so it's kind
of ironic that all of this
infrastructure was packed with
explosives but I guess that makes it
even more functional because now it's a
defense mechanism in addition to being
infrastructure for transportation I love
Switzerland
there's this one bridge that connects
Switzerland to Germany that was built in
2006 and when it was built it was packed
with explosives this bridge was built in
conjunction with Germany Germany paved
half of the bridge and yet they didn't
even know that it was rigged with
explosives it's very aggressive in
Switzerland okay so anyway blowing up
their borders and sealing themselves off
was one major strategy for aggressively
staying neutral let's get on to the next
one
zoom into the lower half of Switzerland
and you'll be struck by one massive
thing that Switzerland has mountains big
giant mountains that flank across the
south part of the country another thing
this was have is an unmatched ability to
drill holes into those mountains the
country has over a thousand tunnels one
of which is 57 kilometers long these
people know how to build holes in
mountains and that skill becomes very
useful when your situation looks like
this most of the population lives here
meaning not in the mountains and so
there wasn't much of a separation
between these population centers and
Nazi Germany after the swiss saw Hitler
marched into Paris and take over huge
portions of France they got serious
about figuring out what they would do if
Hitler invaded so they had their plan to
blow up the borders and slow down
invasion but where could they retreat to
that would allow them to stay neutral
and stay alive during the fighting in
the mountains they were building giant
fortresses and bunkers and tunnels that
were literally inside of the Alps they
built thousands of these things in the
side of mountains and they rigged them
with guns and cannons as well as full-on
bases that were equipped with supplies
and beds and living space sometimes
they'd be hidden in steep mountain
passes disguised as a barn but really it
would be a bunker with hidden explosives
supplies and men ready to fight all over
the Alps the Swiss built these secret
bunkers mainly during World War two in
preparation for any sort of invasion one
the war ended the idea of putting
bunkers in the mountains for defense and
neutrality became pretty embedded in the
Swiss security doctrine as well as just
Swiss culture so I did a call out on
Instagram stories to see if this bunker
culture was still a thing and I got a
lot of responses that showed me that
it's not just world war two in the
mountains Swiss bunkers are all over the
country geez
it's a lot of bunkers thank you to all
of those who sent me pictures of your
bunkers after World War two the new
threat was the Soviet Union and the Cold
War and nuclear destruction bunkers were
now built into homes apartment buildings
hospitals public infrastructure of all
kind had bunkers underneath it by the
1960s Switzerland had built enough
underground bunkers and shelters to
protect the entire population and with a
healthy surplus something that no other
country has ever done okay so let's talk
about the last step here which is kind
of the dark side of Swiss neutrality and
the one that no one really wants to talk
about but got to talk about it
so let me reiterate here that staying
neutral
and safe when this is your situation is
a very difficult thing I mean world war
two was an incredible tragedy where
millions of people lost their lives
during World War Two Switzerland had an
official policy of neutrality this meant
that they would trade with whomever
whether it was the accessing Hitler or
it was the Allies and Churchill but in
reality Switzerland traded a lot more
with Germany providing them with
anti-aircraft guns and other military
supplies and ammunition that was used in
the war
in addition Switzerland allowed the Nazi
regime to store lots of gold and art and
other valuables that were looted from
victims of the war and specifically the
Holocaust not a super good look
defenders of this will tell you that
Switzerland was doing what it needed to
do to stay out of the war to stay
neutral and just like blowing up your
borders or making bunkers in the
mountains this pandering to Hitler and
being kind of on decent terms with the
Third Reich was a way of making it more
costly and more implausible that Germany
would just pop right down south from
where they are to take over this small
country neutrality does not mean holding
hands and singing Kumbaya neutrality in
the Swiss foreign policy doctrine means
deterrence and defense there's a Swiss
military saying that says in order to
remain in peace you have to have cannons
and this kind of sums it up not only did
they have cannons and weaponry but they
also played by whatever rules they
needed to in order to stay out of the
war and it worked
Hitler had a pretty developed plan to
take over Switzerland but in the end it
didn't make strategic sense it was too
costly and implausible for them to take
over their neighbor to the south even
though he had taken over the majority of
the European continent at that point I
will bet a large sum of money that the
top comment on this video is someone
bad-mouthing the Swiss for all of this
world war ii stuff which whatever i
don't have a dog in this fight if that's
how you feel that's how you feel okay so
these two massive global wars are over
and Switzerland is still neutral but
they don't have to take as extreme
measures to remain so so what do you do
with all these bunkers first the bombing
the borders thing were they packed
explosives in all of these bridges and
roads and tunnels turns out that the
military slowly started to dismantle all
of this a few years ago and by 2014 the
military says that all of the mines and
bombs and TNT have been removed from
public infrastructure good for you
military no more bombs at bridges so for
the household bunkers that were built
during the Cold War those are still
there and my friends on Instagram tell
me that they're just kind of used for
like storage rooms or sometimes like as
a laundry room extra space I guess with
really fortified doors that will
withstand the radioactivity of a nuclear
weapon I mean it's not bad to have but
what I'm really interested in is all of
the mountain fortresses and tunnels and
like bunkers that were in the Swiss Alps
what happened to those those were really
expensive to build and we're expensive
to maintain and the military is honestly
have eager to get rid of them some of
them have been sold off and turned into
like fancy hotels in the side of a
mountain others are used as cheese
cellars to make delicious Swiss cheese
and then you've got this one which was
purchased by like a tech security
company that specializes in
keeping your data safe so you can store
your Bitcoin or whatever else you need
on these super secure servers in the
site of a Swiss Mountain they claim
these servers are so protected that they
are impervious even to an
electromagnetic shock from an atom bomb
it seems to me like a little bit of
overkill but if you have some really
important documents and files that you
need to save this is your place but the
majority of these mountain bunkers and
fortresses lie completely abandoned if
you hike around Switzerland you will see
these things everywhere which is
something I've never done and really now
want to do go like bunker hunting in
Switzerland sounds kind of amazing all
right so the Swiss stayed neutral
they've continued to stay neutral they
will probably continue to stay neutral
and it turns out they will use whatever
means necessary to do so thanks for
watching all right I want to tell you
about Squarespace Squarespace is the
sponsor of today's video thank you
Squarespace for supporting this channel
and letting me make this cool video
about Switzerland but also thank you
Squarespace for being a really useful
and user friendly platform where you can
build websites and email campaigns and
all of these things that make running a
business or having a portfolio or being
a creative person a much smoother
experience on the Internet
Squarespace has these beautiful
templates that you can use to quickly
put up a website with whatever branding
you need to do to be able to customize
it but also not have to worry about the
technical nightmare that is designing a
website if you don't know web design I'm
using Squarespace right now to do a
revamp of my own website and my own
social and internet presence and I'm
very pleased with how simple and easy it
is it integrates with email campaigns
which is a really important thing if you
have a business to be able to have email
lists and do email marketing it
integrates with social platforms and
everything you can imagine so if you
want to get a free trial and 10% off
your first purchase of a template or
domain go to Squarespace comm slash
Johnny Harris and you will get this
discount purchasing through this link
help support this channel so it'd be
great if you click the link in the
description or go to squarespace.com
slash Johnny Harris
and check it out Squarespace is great
Thank You Squarespace for sponsoring
this video thank you all for watching
I've got a lot of really cool videos
coming up and I'm really excited to
share them with you alright have a good
day
[Music]